ces petites de ce journal l'arrestation
du gang soupçonné d'avoir participé à
l'enlèvement et la séquestration du
jeune ilan qui est mort après avoir été
torturé pendant plus de trois semaines
dans un appartement de bagneux le chef
de la bande est en fuite la barbarie et
la violence gratuite s'ajoutaient
l'attrait de l'argent facile sous les
verrous ce soir treize personnes de
jeunes adultes qui se répartissaient les
tâches tous ou presque ont grandi dans
cette cité difficile à banyuls in
boudaoud eric messi l'a 26 ans c'est lui
qui se prétend le chef du gang des
barbares sous le nom de the brain aux
barbarians
c'est à dire le cerveau des barbares
suspect numéro un pour la justice
youssef fofana court toujours
il vivait dans ce quartier de bagneux en
région parisienne la nuit dernière il a
échappé au coup de filet de la police
pas ses complices supposés 12 d'entre
eux ont été interpellées la plupart ici
un autre en belgique
ils sont âgés de 17 à 32 ans et seraient
tous impliqués dans l'enlèvement la
séquestration d'ilan halimi semble qu'il
faille distinguer les ceux qui étaient
chargés de l'enlèvement proprement dit
et relation violente de saisie de
l'otage et qu'il y avait un autre groupe
qui était plutôt chargé d'assurer la
détention des geôliers en quelque sorte
ilan halimi a été détenu et torturé
pendant 24 jours dans un appartement
retrouvé par les policiers dans cette
autre cité de bagneux
le jeune homme est tombé dans un piège
tendu par ses ravisseurs sur son lieu de
travail
une jeune fille a servi d'appât le gang
a utilisé plusieurs fille dans son rôle
l'une d'entre elles est à l'origine des
arrestations
ses proches l'ont reconnue dans ce
portrait robot
hier soir elle s'est livrée au
commissariat de montrouge et a tout
raconté avant ilan halimi
la bande avait déjà fait six ou sept
tentatives d'enlèvement différentes
selon les premières auditions le mobile
semble avoir été le même
l'argent ilan halimi a été retrouvé près
de cette voie ferrée agonisant trois
semaines après son rapt il n'a pas
survécu à ses blessures
les obsèques dylan halimi ont eu lieuau
aujourd'hui c'est donc à bagneux qu'il
aura été détenu pendant plusieurs
semaines et torturé par des jeunes qui
ont grandi dans les cités de cette
commune des quartiers où didier briand
et loïc works se sont rendus pour tenter
d'en savoir plus youssef fofana le chef
présumé du gang et ce soir toujours en
fuite
à 26 ans le cerveau des barbares comme
il se fait appeler est extrêmement
dangereuse selon la police ce matin les
enquêteurs étaient venus l'interpeller
chez lui dans cette cité de bagneux
mais ils se seraient volatilisés il ya
deux semaines devant l'appartement
nous tentons de discuter avec ses
parents les voisins parlent d'une
famille discrète sans histoire y compris
au sujet du fils us f
mes parents m'ont sont des gens qui
travaillent qui part très tout ce qui
rentre tard je connais bien la petite
chaîne fils à qui tu sors d'une jeune
fille adorable était toujours seul tous
tension
j'avais toujours seulement mais jamais
d'amis
je voyais souvent soir est donc sauf
aléas et la cabine
derrière ses complices présumés ont été
arrêtés ce matin principalement dans
cette cité de bagneux
ils ont entre 17 et 32 ans la plupart
sans emploi les policiers parlent de
jeunes sans repères pratiquant une
extrême violence
on a affaire donc à des gens qui sont
issus et qui sauf qu'ils ont grandi qui
sont allés à l'école et au collège dans
une même cité et qui au fil des années
semblent avoir constitué ce qu'on
appelait avant une association de
malfaiteurs une organisation criminelle
voir maintenant un gang
l'un d'eux des membres a pris
certainement dû à ça sur sa personnalité
une autorité naturelle les enquêteurs de
la brigade criminelle ont quatre jours
pour mieux cerner les personnalités les
motivations des membres présumés du gang
dans la sphère de l'assassinât de
géraldine giraud et de katia lherbier
une confrontation inédite en ce moment
même à sens
le principal suspect jean pierre treiber
est interrogé en compagnie des autres
mises en examen
marie christine van kempen et patricia
darbeau l'objectif de cet interrogatoire
est de savoir si ces trois personnes
s'étaient rencontrés avant l'assassinât
comme l'affirment un témoin à bagneux
c'est la stupéfaction les habitants et
les voisins de la cité en afrique c'est
dans un appartement d'un des quartiers
qui a été séquestré ilan halimi dans les
obsèques se sont déroulées ce matin au
cimetière de pantin et spontanément des
bougies ont été déposées près de son
lieu de travail
anouk burel massant ferreira
fermé en mémoire dylan lit-on sur le
papier les commerçants du quartier n'ont
pas eu le coeur à travailler eux sont
venus spontanément apporté des fleurs
des bougies lire des prières sur le
boulevard voltaire à paris
c'est une véritable dérive on est
révolté les commerçants ne veulent pas
parler je dit tout haut ce que je pense
un animal on n'aurait pas fait ça le
jeune homme a été enterré dans la
matinée et l'arrestation des membres
présumés du gang soulage dans le
quartier je vous laisse avec impatience
et un plaisir de le montant qu'ils ont
été arrêtés ici la majorité pense que
l'enlèvement avait un caractère
antisémite
même si à ce jour l'enquète ne le
démontre pas au quartier des tertres à
bagneux où les interpellations ont eu
lieu les habitants n'en reviennent pas
le chef de gang habitait dans cet
immeuble sa famille est effondrée
ses voisins atterré jusqu'à maintenant
j'ai deux choses le calme des bons
joueurs en font rien du tout
marie hélène amiable maire de bagneux ne
cache pas son émotion
je suis ému bien sûr c'est une situation
c'est une situation difficile pour qu'on
ait une ville et pour ses habitants bien
évidemment quand il arrivait une chose
une chose d'une telle importance un tel
drame
dans la matinée les habitants ou appris
que le jeune ilan aurait été séquestrée
dans cet immeuble une rue calme dans une
cité sans problème
l' enquête sur le gang qui a enlevé
torturé à mort le jeune ilan le réseau
serait apparemment plus important que
prévu et en dehors de celui qui se fait
appeler le surf des barbares d'autres
membres seraient en fit le point avec
amaury guibert et olivier robert à la
brigade criminelle de paris les gardes à
vue sans chaînes au moins une dizaine
mais leur nombre varie car les
enquêteurs ont la conviction que les
membres du gang de bagneux sont sans
doute plus nombreux que prévu
six personnes sont d'ailleurs activement
recherché en plus du chef présumé
youssouf fofana
audrey 24 ans est l'une des premières
mises en examen dans le dossier
cette étudiante qui voulait devenir
assistante sociale et la petite amie
d'un membre du gang
elle est soupçonnée d'avoir servi
d'appât lors d'au moins une tentative
d'enlèvement
mais devant les enquêteurs elle a
précisé avoir refusé de séduire ilan
halimi
mais c'est que quelqu'un a été kidnappé
on va le relancer très vite contre de
l'argent
bon dans ce milieu là on donne pas son
petit ami pour une affaire de
l'extorsion de fonds mais c'est la vie
lors de la faire là il n'a pas hésité
une seconde
les enquêteurs essayent maintenant de
mieux comprendre le fonctionnement du
gang mais aussi ses éventuels
antécédents ainsi des rapprochements
seraient en cours avec la campagne de
raquette qui a visé des médecins
parisiens en mars 2005 il avait accordé
des arrêts de travail complaisant avant
d'être l'objet de chantages une grenade
avait même explosé devant le cabinet de
l'un d'entre eux dans le 16e
arrondissement de paris
en enlevant ilan halimi et en se lançant
dans le kidnapping crapuleux le gang
aurait donc franchi un palier en fin
d'après midi une marche en mémoire du
jeune homme a été organisée à paris
silencieuse au départ la manifestation a
tourné à l'appel à la vengeance
un peu plus tard notre équipe a été
agressé par plusieurs individus aux
visages masqués
jacques chirac et dominique de villepin
sisteron jeudi soir à paris à la
cérémonie à la mémoire d'ilan halimi à
la grande synagogue de la victoire
la présence des deux plus hauts
personnages de l'exécutif devrait donner
un caractère national à ce rassemblement
dix jours après la mort du jeune vendeur
enlevé et torturé
l'enquète continue sur le gang des
barbares en france mais aussi en côte
d'ivoire où se trouverait le chef
présumé
le point avec jeanne assouly le gardien
de l'immeuble où ilan halimi avait été
séquestré est poursuivi pour complicité
de séquestration en bande organisée
ils auraient sous-loué en cachette cet
appartement où le jeune homme a été
retenu et torturé pendant deux semaines
ils auraient facilité l'accès à la
chaufferie de l'immeuble où la victime
serait probablement resté une semaine
avant d'être abandonnée agonisante dans
l'essonne le gardien dit ignorer ce qui
se passait dans l'immeuble il a été mise
en examen et incarcéré mercredi
au total 13 personnes ont été mises en
examen
onze d'entre elles ont été placées en
détention provisoire par ailleurs deux
personnes ont été interpellées mardi en
région parisienne trois autres suspects
sont maintenues en garde à vue à aix en
provence et à marseille
les cinq personnes devrait être déféré
en fin de semaine mais le chef de gang
présumé court toujours
youssouf fofana serait en côte d'ivoire
abidjan
sur place deux enquêteurs français
assistent leurs collègues de la police
judiciaire ivoirienne il aurait une
piste un homme portant le même nom que
le principal suspect aurait séjourné
dans cet hôtel
jeudi soir une cérémonie aura lieu à la
mémoire d'ilan halimi à la grande
synagogue de paris jacques chirac et
dominique de villepin y assisteront
autre actualité de cette journée cette
cérémonie aux allures d'une union sacrée
qui s'est déroulée il ya quelques
instants la synagogue de la victoire à
paris il s'agit vous le savez de rendre
hommage au jeune ilan halimi enlevé
torturé et tué notamment parce qu'il
était juif c'est en tout cas une des
pistes retenues par la justice fait
exceptionnel
jacques chirac assisté à cette cérémonie
ainsi que de nombreuses personnalités
g-fit imbert frédérick basile
c'est une cérémonie religieuse ce soir
le kaddish la prière dite après un décès
devaient être lus pour ilan halimi avant
un discours du grand rabbin sitruk un
moment religieux donc même si dans la
synagogue de la rue de la victoire à
paris
l'hommage va bien au delà de la
communauté juive le président de la
république arrive peu avant 19 heures
accompagné de son épouse jacques chirac
avait téléphoné à la mer dylan
avant-hier dominique de villepin est
également présent ce matin le premier
ministre confirmait le premier
l'arrestation de youssouf fofana
gilles de robien catherine colonna de
nombreux ministres sont là aux aussi en
fait la droite et la gauche sont réunis
ce soir de ségolène royal à dominique
strauss kahn mais aussi françois
hollande de françois bayrou à philippe
de villiers beaucoup d'autres à
l'extérieur comme à l'intérieur ils
disent les mêmes mots indignation et
solidarité c'est un acte de solidarité à
la garde d'une famille qui a été touché
dans sa chair
c'est aussi un acte de solidarité à
l'égard des jus de france qui se sentent
concernés par ce crime odieux
ce que nous avons vécu noir plus revoir
par contre les déclarations de
manifestation c'est bien mais peut être
porté vers l'est au delà l'union sacrée
des politiques etc humanisme des
religieux monseigneur andré vingt-trois
archevêque de paris assistent à la
cérémonie tout comme dalil boubakeur
au nom des musulmans de france
c'est donc en tant que musulman
bussières venu apporter et mon réconfort
ma compassion par tyra thème de la
famille à laquelle je pense très fort et
en particulier la maman de
d'ultimes dylan la synagogue de la rue
de la victoire peut accueillir 1500
personnes dans les rues alentour
plusieurs milliers d'autres sont
rassemblés ce soir à la mémoire dit
l'analyste ce nouveau développement dans
l' enquête sur le gang de bagneux
d'abord ilan halimi aurait été tué après
avoir vu peut-être ses ravisseurs c'est
du moins une hypothèque sérieusement
envisagée deuxième élément du jour
l'interpellation d'une adolescente qui
aurait servi d'appât le point nos
querelles leurs rangs des bois très
agitée peu coopératif
youssouf fofana ici sous un drap blanc
restera 48 heures de plus en garde à vue
à abidjan des auditions difficiles selon
les enquêteurs
sans remords ni regrets le cerveau du
gang des barbares aurait même menacé les
policiers durant l'interrogatoire son
retour soumis à une procédure
d'extradition ne devrait pas intervenir
avant la semaine prochaine à paris les
gardes à vue se succèdent au 36 quai des
orfèvres
l'enquète avance à grands pas
arrestation importante les policiers
détiennent la jeune fille qui a attiré
ilan halimi dans le piège
une jeune et jolie brune qui avait pour
mission de le séduire
elle n'a que 16 ans elle est d'origine
iranienne
elle vit avec sa mère et sa soeur dans
un pavillon coquet au nord de paris
son petit ami aurait lui aussi fait
partie du gang
elle est venue à la rencontre dylan dans
ce magasin du boulevard voltaire
trois jours plus tard il a rejoint au
parc de sceaux c'est dans cette allée
que les enquêteurs retrouvent la voiture
du jeune homme
la jeune fille a reconnu les faits lors
de sa garde à vue à ce jour quatorze
personnes ont été mises en examen
les enquêteurs recherchent toujours les
hommes de main de youssouf fofana
les enquêteurs qui commence également à
mieux cerner les activités du réseau et
bien avant l'enlèvement dylan on
découvre qu'un certain nombre de
personnalités ont été menacés victime de
chantage et d'extorsion de fonds comme
le pdg de la chaîne arte jérôme clément
ou encore l'ancien président de médecins
sans frontières rony brauman tous deux
ont été les cibles du gang ian frontier
arnauld miguet depuis plus de trois ans
youssef fofana et son entourage auraient
multiplié les tentatives d'extorsion de
fonds comme l'a révélé ce matin le
quotidien libération sous des noms
d'emprunt en utilisant par exemple
sigle de groupes clandestins corses il
aurait tenté de racketter plusieurs
personnalités comme rony brauman ancien
président de médecins sans frontières
une enveloppe certainement boîte aux
lettres qui contenait à la fois une
lettre me menaçant de mort me réclamant
l'impôt révolutionnaire puisque cette
lettre était signée d'armata corsa et on
nous demandait de verser plus de 300000
euros et quelques mois plus tard à peu
près même épisode les mêmes même forme
même l'être même enveloppe mais cette
fois ci accompagné d'un coup de feu dans
mon portail et d'un jet de cocktail
molotov dans la cour de la maison les
mêmes menaces les mêmes tentative
d'intimidation jérôme clément le patron
d'arte et les a reçu lui aussi
accompagné d'une vidéo explicite qu'est
cette vidéo représentaient des gens
encagoulés armés utilisant des bazookas
des mitraillettes et y rencontre des
cibles combrié pas en disant c'était
voilà ce qui va vous arriver si vous si
vous ne versez pas la rançon
autre victime maître joseph cohen sabban
at il été choisi à cause de ses origines
juives l'avocat pénaliste s'interroge
pourquoi moi parce que je m'appelle
cohen sabban ce qui est l'étendard juifs
par excellence je m'appelle cohen sabban
est ce que c'est un cela qui a provoqué
le ciblage est ce ma fonction d'avocat
ma profession d'avocat les 2 c parmi
rétrospectivement effectivement un seul
sentiment de très très désagréable
malaise sur la vingtaine de cibles
choisies par le groupe
toutes n'étaient pas juives mais tout
résidait dans le sud de paris d'où est
originaire youssef fofana ainsi que ses
complices présumés
autre lien établi par la police dans
chaque affaire y compris le rapt et le
meurtre dylan une même cabine
téléphonique a même cybercafés ont été
utilisés
mobilisation nationale aujourd'hui à la
mémoire d'ilan halimi à paris cent mille
manifestants sont attendus pour cette
marche contre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme
la présence du front national et du
mouvement pour la france suscite la
polémique
al'annonce de leur participation le mrap
a décidé de se retirer jean françois cyr
et à bagneux jeudi ils étaient 350 à
défiler en la mémoire d'ilan halimi
cet après midi à paris ils devraient
être plus de 100000 parmi eux des
responsables politiques notamment du
front national depuis un certain nombre
de mois il ya une montée d'un certain
antisémitisme
il est directement à l'immigration moi
j'ai au moins le courage de le dire ce
que personne n a le courage de faire
colère des organisateurs
ils l'ont annoncé ils empêcheront le fn
de manifester à leurs côtés les
autorités qui dirigent le front national
ont été condamnés à plusieurs reprises
pour des faits relevant soit du racisme
anti arabe soit de l'antisémitisme
antijuifs la présence cet après-midi du
souverainiste philippe de villiers
dérange elle aussi mais elle est
acceptée son parti rappelle le crif n'a
jamais été condamné pour propos racistes
conséquence le mrap entre autres aux
associations ne se joindra pas au
cortège
toutes les tendances politiques elles
seront représentées
le parti communiste a confirmé sa
participation la france contre le
racisme et l'antisémitisme sous cette
banderole plus de 30000 80000 ou deux
cent mille personnes selon les sources
ont marché ensemble
cet après midi dans les rues de paris
pour dire l'horreur quinze jours après
la découverte du corps du jeune ilan
halimi torturé à mort voyez ce reportage
de stéphanie perez et bruno l'hiver
dans les rangs serrés ils parlent d'une
même voix contre la barbarie qui a
conduit à la mort dylan ceux qui ont
fait le déplacement cet après midi sont
en grande majorité de confession juive
solidarité clairement affichée d'une
communauté qui affirme être victime d'un
antisémitisme grandissant que les
quantités j'attaque les notaires
l'antisémitisme profondeur depuis des
décennies et chaque fois qu'il ya
quelque chose
les juifs les juifs les fruits sont là
on appartient une communauté où on est
toujours excuse pour le malheur
au delà de la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme ce sont surtout les
valeurs de la république que d'autres
sont venus défendre un réflexe citoyen
qu'il juge indispensable la barbarie le
passage à l'acte
le fait que des gens en arrivent à faire
ça aujourd'hui dans notre pays c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est
incroyable
et ça peut arriver à n'importe qui il y
aura il a aujourd'hui et là demain bien
sûr
ou peut-être franche faut même pier
import
l'horreur elle est inacceptable d'un
problème jusque là ces problèmes d'un
jeune homme qui a été assassiné après
torturer rentable et ça c'est quelque
chose que tout être humain ne peut pas
accepter
on est dans un pays qui est une
démocratie donc le doute de ce pays
unanime cry for study
parmi ceux qui ont appelé à manifester
certaines associations de lutte contre
le racisme le rassemblement
d'aujourd'hui est aussi une nouvelle
occasion pour la france de se pencher
sur sa mixité culturelle
si on trouve que la france est très
plein de culture et je compte partage
quand se soutiennent entre mouy je te
vient passer de soutien et 7 me fait de
la peine
il me semble que le meur prix à
n'aligner ceux des tra cour se montre
moi c'était française pour montrer qu'il
est de nouveau purgeant de se mobiliser
et d'agir surtout comment faire en sorte
de militer pour le vivre ensemble et de
concert une société respectueuse
dézinguer votre local leurs différences
encadrés par un important dispositif
policier la manifestation s'est déroulée
dans le calme sans incident majeur à
signaler
[Musique]